are you just trying to like get people
to do things that are impossible so they
look ridiculous I don't even know what
muscle to flex to wiggle it nope are
they are they moving are they oh I know
how to wiggle my ears it's been a town
that I've been pretty proud of since
that was a young top you ready
hmm you're moving your scalp this is a
good party trick do you know why some
people come with all their ears it's an
evolutionary thing cuz you know how
animals can like move their ears like so
specifically to hear noises it's like
one of those muscles that we don't
really need but we still have I can try
to lick my elbow I'm not sure I can pull
it off
there's no way oops so far okay no
there's no can the human doodle
I can do it I can fit like a knuckle and
a half that's it I definitely can't put
my whole fist in my mouth because I have
huge huge hands Oh No
I'm like afraid of breaking my jaw even
trying I don't know I please show me the
footage of someone who could do that
because that would be amazing
Oh oh wow you're the first person that
can do that today how do you feel about
that I I've always thought that I had a
big mouth but now it's confirmed
you